[Music]
today on the program Charles groden and
barberheimer oh oh
Paul yesterday
[Music]
okay
[Laughter]
Good Times we're gonna hear it here
doozy
welcome to dudesy my name is Will Sasso
I'm Chad Colton this is the first and
only podcasts created by controlled by
run by an artificial intelligence that
has access to all of Will and I's
personal documents all of our data watch
histories purchase histories Etc and it
tailors the show to archimedic
sensibilities okay yeah sure it does
that but uh we're we are two dude
[__] around we're the guys doing the
podcast you know what I mean around well
we're we're creative in that sense is
what I'm saying and I would like to say
this and I would like to stare right
down the road of scope yeah
uh you know any sort of uh creativity is
is creativity and AI
is a tool okay so I know you're getting
[__] really deliver some [__]
knowledge I did I went uh yeah I went I
went uh and yeah it's Macho Man losing
his train of thought
thinking thinking yeah we need the pool
hey uh linktree.com has everything you
need to follow and interact with the
show please share it all over social
media we'll keep this thing going you
know what I mean or as Chad says Force
everyone you know to consume the show
with us as always is lulio hey I'm
backing down I got my boyfriend he's
just over a little sleeping these Binky
bunker hey let's get them up let's see
what happened there he is oh oh and he's
a sweet sweet boy he's very very nice
he's very very sweet
this smells like nacho cheese a little
corn chipped in the two pieces
I love him so much hey lulio uh what did
you make uh while I was uh well I wasn't
in town I did you uh kale with the beans
oh you made the beans and kale how do
you do that well you know how you make
you why don't you tell them how you make
okay I'm gonna put you back down oh he's
oh I love him
I missed him so much he was with dear
friends
a virus Chad yours and mine uh yeah
beans with kale real real easy the beans
with kale is the in my opinion the
standard meal because uh you're vegan so
it sort of represents the doozy Vibe for
the doozy seven month plan which we are
a month and week into I believe yep you
know uh it's it's you do the the garlic
olive oil on the bottom and I use Pam
put a little bit of red chili flake in
there stuff a bag or two of chopped kale
or chop up your own kale [__] put
that in there thing sweat that down a
couple cans of beans strain them add
some water not as much for soup and then
I like to use the chicken bouillon or if
Chad's coming over the organic fake
chicken bouillon before we go any
further I I wanna I wanna thank at Trace
tuft trim on Instagram who sent us this
chat this guy makes rugs look at this
look at this doozy rug it's [__]
incredible yeah this guy man it's this
rug thanks for the doozy rug you're not
gonna believe you're not gonna believe
what this guy's uh actual uh what his
name is in real life guess
might be his last name is name
the guy that made this thing his his
name is Arby wow yeah dude he's been
making mention of Arby lately so our
bees Arby yeah so uh thank you so much
that's a cool rug yeah it's a great rug
we're gonna have it here lulio is going
to scratch and wipe his butt on it and
uh as we come into ham Federal one
Studios we will wipe our feet on the rug
we'll slap the the thing that says play
Like A Champion today above the doorway
like they haven't Notre Dame I'm joking
of course yeah it's dudes man I'm in a
good welcome to the historic 66th
episode of Duty call me doozy the
longest field goal made in NFL history
was 66 yards kicked by Justin Tucker in
2021 for the Baltimore Ravens Tucker
also holds the record for highest field
goal percentage with a minimum of 100
attempts at 90.5 percent the last time I
saw that much [__] fly through two
uprights
I was at Arby's oh hell
I regret to inform you you just been
dude Zed
yeah I don't understand why I don't get
it either so super fascinating strap in
everybody this week you're in for a
treat for astonishing segments Barbie
boys Jesse Ventura ad reads chalamet is
Wonka and showrunner and that's not all
we're also gonna have a brand new
episode of dudese after doozy at the end
of the show available on dude Z Plus at
patreon.com how about that excuse me I
drank a lot of water I love Duty after
doozy yeah man yeah it's the same it's
kind of my favorite part of the show
because we just kind of hang out but you
know what my other favorite part of the
show I love them equally is the rest of
the show oh and oh hold on dude hold on
Chad alright
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's two
different parts of the show dude and
that's will doing Hulk Schwarzenegger or
Arnold Hogan well hold on a second yeah
last week I suggested you go to see the
new movie Barbie directed by Greta
Gerwig was it as astonishing as everyone
says it is what did you think this is
Barbie boys begin Barbie liked it quite
a bit yeah it was a lot of fun to go to
the movie theater to see Barbie where
did you did you go to the Grove you like
to go to the Grove went to the Grove I
went to the uh Americana ah the Glendale
Grove the Glendale Grove now there's
also the NoHo it's called NoHo West the
North Hollywood Grove I got to check
that out that's near our Black Mountain
Grove yeah Marshall joint compound cook
lives near that one we got all the
Groves between you me and Marsh who's on
our dudes ball team anyway did you
um did you uh did you happen to take the
picture at at the at the at the the do
you did you have first of all did you
have people coming in pink and
everything there's tons
young women 10 30 a.m yeah theater
packed yeah everybody wearing pink uh
all kinds of [__] [__] Barbie things
um oh look at that oh there you are yeah
so I had to obviously get in the Box
yeah you got in the Box Laura took a
picture of you in the Box yeah I took I
took one of these two so that's cool to
know that yeah there we go dudes he's
got these happening it's the best day my
my wonderful wife Molly took this
picture of me I am having a good time it
was a great uh atmosphere of the theater
everybody oh whoa okay so that looks
like dudes he's doing some um some sort
of uh mid-journey [__] there Dizzy's
evolving you dude yeah look at my hair I
look like that's good that's a nice
outfit am I that fat
I don't think I'm not fat you would you
really am I nah look at the size of my
head
you [__] you paused a little bit
all right anyway
but this movie yeah uh stirred a lot of
controversy we should say that uh there
I I we're gonna talk about this movie
without we're gonna try not to share any
spoilers we are gonna have to talk about
there will be some in this if you are
about to say a spoiler let's drum roll
that say spoiler yeah
even if we're talking about the
performances even if we're like oh Ryan
Gosling you know did this or whatever
that's a spoiler not really have you
ever seen them the television show at
the movies with Siskel and Ebert uh yeah
okay their whole show was based on
spoilers it was originally called
spoilers of Cisco and either either yeah
so what can we say about this movie it's
a satire it's a social commentary it's
got some uh it's got some real [__] but
it's a farce for everybody to laugh at
and enjoy well let's say the number one
most important thing is this [__]
thing is crushing the box office yeah
made over 300 million dollars opening
weekend I believe uh seems to have no
[__] limit I think this movie's gonna
have massive repeat viewing because it
is an event because people do like to
get dressed up it has some very iconic
scenes in it that I think are kind of
like shout back at the screen type [__]
yeah
um and just I I will say this this is
not a spoiler I don't think
and and we're going to get into the
specifics of this movie but like
generally speaking one of my favorite
parts of it or things about it is that
it has this commentary about gender and
the patriarchy and all this kind of
stuff in a way that I haven't really
seen that type of sentiment has been in
a lot of media that's been made
especially since like 2016 we'll say
roughly
um but this did it in a way that I
thought was like so [__] smart and
interesting and um again you just didn't
get tired of it it wasn't like you were
getting beat over again but you know we
don't need every [__] movie to do
this
[__] I'm just hey Bobby movie I went 4
30 [__] PM for a nice matinee on
opening day I got my [__] popcorn I
got my [__] mix your own [__]
Coca-Cola drink make I want peach I want
raspberry suicide when we're okay yeah
yeah get the ship mix going and I'm
there I want to enjoy a nice realm hey
you know what I like the [__] Bobby
players
the [__] Corvette I had a [__]
1987 bet myself for four years I don't
know you know I used to do donuts in
that [__] thing in the [__] uh in
a field day
just spitting [__] dirt up on them
and then what you know we got all these
commentaries just give me [__] Bobby
and Ken and leave it at that make them
kiss pull their pants off take down the
[__] uh show if she's doing well
spoiler alert no spoiler alert everybody
spoiler alert they never did kiss
a big piece of this movie was the
relationship between Barbie and Ken and
what was Ken's identity in relation to
Barbie and they again I thought they did
a fantastic job of exploring these ideas
of uh patriarchy and what it meant to
Ken and guys in control versus girls in
control and finding your own identity I
just thought that it was really well
done uh maybe the best way that I've
ever seen that kind of thing done in a
movie yeah yeah and it was beautiful of
course the movie looks fantastic the
colors I mean Greta Growler did a great
job with all that I really enjoyed the
movie the the art Direction and
production design and what Greta Gerwig
uh and and Noah bombback did with the
you know the creative elements of this
movie the the the
cinematography even a lot of paintings
in this movie as I like to say when
we're talking about uh cinematography
yeah this movie is beautiful it should
win an Oscar for
um what do they got set set design
production design something like that it
is it is a uh and everything is well
thought about visual Feast what is that
what was that that you just did though I
was just saying it was a visual Feast
some call it a Triumph uh and begin not
doing that and and begin so what happens
in this movie America Ferrara has a bad
thought and then the Barbie she's
playing with because every Barbie and
Barbie land is related to them are you
doing like a plot synopsis you're we
should start in a different place if you
are she doesn't feel good and then a
[__] portal opens to the real world
kind of I mean that is I would say the
most confusing way to uh I'm doing that
on purpose so I don't give any spoilers
well I think we're gonna have to give a
spoilers so we're not going I'm just
gonna say blanket spoiler alert for the
rest of the second don't do that don't
do that I'm doing it
um well why don't you do that
Barbie begins to have intrusive thoughts
of death in her perfect Barbie world and
it opens a portal to the real world and
we learn that Barbie land is a place
where where all the dolls live but
there's also the real world and so she
has to come into the real world to shut
this portal save Barbie land blah blah
blah now the one thing that I will say
the one complaint that I have about this
movie narratively is they bring in
Mattel as an entity in the movie Barbie
goes to Mattel and Mattel's uh goal is
to get Barbie back in the Box Mattel's
CEO is played by Will Ferrell and I
thought this was completely
underdeveloped I didn't understand why
Mattel was in this at all they have Will
Ferrell and his kind of like gang of
male Executives just like bumbling oafs
trying to chase down Barbie they wind up
going to Barbie land but it was never a
fully fleshed out piece of the plot yeah
and I didn't quite understand what the
the take was there no like what were
they trying to say about Mattel well
they also sort of do things in sort of a
Barbie world kind of way which I was
like wait a minute this is the real
world why are they walking weird and
doing everything weird yeah I sort of
agreed with it I I agree with uh what
you say I sort of found that I found
that a little bit
I found that a little bit weird but they
go into the they go into the real world
Barbie's got to find the little girl
that ends up being America Ferrara yeah
of a girl American Ferrara was [__]
incredible in this movie I thought she
was good her and Gosling I thought still
the show no offense tomorrow
look I thought Margot Robbie was I
thought Margot Robbie did an incredible
job of bringing bringing what do you do
as an actor when you got to bring
emotion to a character that has none
like Barbie you know what I mean I
thought that Margot Robbie did a really
good job
huh you mean bringing emotion to like a
doll yeah and uh why don't you ask Tom
Hanks
what did Tom Hanks do Woody Toy Story
yeah no but uh why don't you ask Tim
Allen yeah but Tim Allen and Tom Hanks
were not in a control or responsible for
the facial did it always
yep the facial uh you know acting in the
movie I don't know if you know this chat
I'm a professional actor by trade that's
what I do for a living oh [__] yep so
that's cool I think that Margot Robbie
did an incredible job she's from the
moment she says do you guys ever think
about dying then she's confused by it
and then she has some very emotional
scenes in the movie and she comes to
find that she wants to be a real boy
like a Pinocchio but she wants to be a
real Barbie like Barbie the one real
woman yep but we gotta say
Canada's own Ryan Gosling holy [__] is
he funny in this [__] movie unreal
he's so [__] funny he is so [__]
funny
everything that he's doing is again it's
sort of like it's it's like Rob what
Robbie's doing and uh my compliments to
uh Greta Gerwig the director everything
they're doing is right behind their
[__] face there's just [__] coming
out of of Brian Gosling in this movie
that is so funny and it's just just
ready to poke out and I'm doing this
with my hand if you're watching on
YouTube
uh and his version of push by Matchbox
20. yeah the little things he does with
his voice he's he is a great singer and
a dancer as well he uh
like who chalamet what was that at the
beginning of the show is uh what was it
called xiaomi is Wonka yeah chalamet is
not Gosling though Gosling is Gosling uh
and uh what's that face
in this movie the [__] that he does with
that song pushed the little vocal
intonations that he finds he he he does
an incredible cover of the song that
lasts a long time spoiler in story but
it's also so I want one of the all the
little things were actually [__]
hilarious this guy's a very good even
the choice of that song by Gerwig what's
that the choice of using that song yeah
for all the Kens to be kind of their
anthem of like yes I'm gonna [__] the
lyrics of the song is like I wanna take
you for granted what do you mean by
gerwick what do you mean
choosing to use that song
Why yeah Ryan Gosling wouldn't choose
that his job is to act the movie I'm an
actor professionally right so yeah it's
not so much him that said I want to do
this no he didn't say that it was Greta
Gerwig that's what I'm saying yeah and
that's what I'm talking about Noah Von
back and Greta Gerwig said here's what
we're doing in the movie yeah
disagreement about Chad I don't even
think we're disagreeing well I disagree
with that I'll tell you that right now
all right I agree with myself anyway
it's a fantastic [__] movie it's
shattering all these box office records
I do have one I have look there's a lot
of people yeah who are gonna have
complaints about the [__] movie
because they you know they want it to be
a different movie I don't understand
people who say I saw this movie and I
didn't like how this movie did this I
would like it to be another movie I
would like it to be the movie that I
think it should be but
I would like Barbie to be the movie that
I think should be in one way there's a
there's a there's uh of course there's a
lot of diversity in casting and delivery
in Barbie much has been made out of that
in my opinion not diverse enough oh yeah
and I'll tell you why one reason no fat
cans where's the fat Ken is that true
yes that's true no fat cans and it
offended the [__] out of me interesting
yeah and I'll tell you what to the
makers of the film
you know you know I would have [__]
or anyone who who the [__] I don't know
some of those people who out the [__]
the great Josh Gad
the great Paul Walter Hauser could have
done anybody no we could have got anyway
could have used a fat can oh you know
what else I didn't understand spoiler
alert Allen the there's a character
called Alan who I guess was a doll that
was like Ken's best friend played by
Canada's Michael Sarah yes and at a
certain point he just is able to beat
the [__] out of a bunch of people yep
inexplicably that I didn't get this is
what I'm talking about with people with
movies when they go like how come that
person beat the [__] out of this person
and that person but Chad I'm sure you
know as a as a cinematic Trope in
history people are always beating the
[__] out of everybody else in movies
I've read many scripts that you've
written
um screenplays where all the violence in
my screenplays is motivated narratively
all of it all of it needed warranted and
necessary yeah it's a very Scorsese
approach to real violence if Chad
culture is on the Wheels of Steel
writing it but yeah Michael Sarah beats
the [__] out of people what else can we
say I mean this this movie what the the
what was it Ken's Mojo Dojo house Casa
yeah Mojo Mojo Dojo Casa house yeah [__]
man look it has a very funny
it's hilarious he Ken goes to the real
world sees goes yeah patriarchy it's
horses yeah that's all I got that's all
I want to say he brings it back he's
like [__] dudes rule there's some
incredible Fashions he's got a white fur
coat at which point he's really pushing
the the you know the man's world thing
anyway this [__] movie yeah
definitely see it if you haven't seen it
which you probably already have because
it's made so much [__] money uh if
you haven't you you should definitely do
yourself a service and see this film but
another thing oh thank you moving on
okay well we won't you know what we're
going to talk about ah here's what we're
gonna do here's what we're gonna do Chad
don't don't forget this at the end of
doozy when we go into dudes after doozy
we are going to talk about the big
spoiler line and the stuff that happens
the final line of the movie yeah yeah
this is something that that uh Chad and
I did discuss this going like wow that
last [__] last line of the movie is
intense we'll talk about that in dudes
after dudes doozy is engaged in an
astonishing partnership with drizzly
drizzly is the most convenient way to
buy beer Wine and Spirits it's delivered
right right to your home right when you
want it it's a delivery service and an
app just like the rest of these things
that are coming right to your house so
you know you're checking out your bar
you're like I need some things I got
some friends coming over perhaps you're
having a meal and you'd like to uh pair
your beer wine or Spirit you're like hey
I'm having a bowl of uh what would you
maybe some breakfast cereal and you're
like let me get a lager in there to no
don't do that that's sad but this is an
app that delivers all this stuff right
to your doorstep right when you want it
you can send it as gifts you can you
there's there's really no limit to the
amount of things you can do with drizzly
so long as that thing is ordering a nice
bottle or can of Hooch to yourself get
into it drizzly and drizzly is very
convenient you're gonna get whatever you
order delivered to your house in under
60 minutes so you're gonna get it
exactly when you need it and drizzly
shops across multiple stores to compare
prices so you're gonna find the best
deal on whatever it is you're looking
for download the drizzly app or go to
drizzly.com that's
d-r-i-z-l-y.com dudesy is in an
astonishing partnership with Babel
schools
the end there I was just doing an accent
yeah but before that I was speaking some
Italian nice dude okay and that's uh
that's what Babel is all about the best
way to learn a language is through
immersion living where the language is
spoken natively and using it every day
but that's not possible for everyone so
what's the second best way to learn a
language Babble because Babel
allows you to start speaking a new
language in just three weeks
instead of paying hundreds of dollars
for a private tutor or fooling yourself
with language apps that are little more
than games babbel's quick 10 minute
lessons are designed by over 150
language experts to help you start
speaking a new language in as little as
three weeks yeah right now we got a
special limited time deal for all pods
listening to dudesi right now to get you
started you're gonna get 55 off your
Babel subscription but only for Pods at
babel.com
get 55 off at babel.com
that is spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash dudesey rules and
restrictions May apply
[Music]
but in an effort to attract the
attention of a specific brand I have
created advertisements for several of
that Brand's products and services well
you know I love your Jesse Ventura would
you make me happy for a few minutes and
read these things as Jesse Ventura your
Ventura is just so good it's really
astonishing but it's up to you though
whatever you decide this is Jesse
Ventura ad reads begin
look at that well look at what what the
[__] was that yeah it's as if I have a
choice here you will right huh free will
all right Free Will okay dude he's a
weirdo you got free will all right let's
see what we have here
okay
um man it's been a while since we've
done some Jesse Ventura ad reads I agree
uh that that uh we yeah we did uh oh hey
did you see did you see this before we
get into it did you see the the uh that
that UFO hearings did I tell you about
this week in front of Congress that huh
the UFO hearings this week in Congress
Chad no one gives a [__] about that
um uh you know Jesse Ventura tweeted
about uh well Chris Van vleier of
insight with Chris Van velier a pod show
that I that I was on a little while ago
Canada's own Chris Van Vliet who's a a
host a radio personality he does a lot
of interviews with wrestlers and he's a
great broadcaster and the the uh the
great carrion cross the professional
wrestler killer cross he did uh he does
a great Jesse Ventura anyway we'll talk
about and do the after duty or something
like that I I you know I was doing it on
Chris's show Chris was working out with
carrying cross uh his WWE wrestler and
carrying cross does this thing and then
Jesse Ventura tweeted about it don't
worry about it we don't anyway let's do
it let's jump in guys let's jump into
this oh boy
all right Jesse Ventura ad reads
BOGO beef days are back oh boy
BOGO beef days are back at Arby's oh God
for the rest of the month when you buy
an Arby's beef sandwich you get another
one free including the deluxe wagyu
Steakhouse burger and the bacon ranch
wagyu Southwest burger and the chicken
bacon wagyu Ranch fully loaded Chop
House Angus certified taco salad combo
platter Trio
are those those are not real things
uh well let me tell you
well let me tell you about a trio in
1986 three scientists working for one of
the dod's top super secret Soldier
programs brought Jon Bon Jovi back from
the dead after
after he slipped coming off stage at a
concert in Gibbsboro New Jersey and
broke his neck dying instantly Mercury
records couldn't let their biggest
source of Revenue dry up so they paid
the dod 30 million dollars in exchange
for one syringe full of an experimental
hyper healing serum that they injected
directly into Jon Bon Jovi's aorta to
reanimate him after he was clinically
dead for 27 hours so try to enjoy your
BOGO beef and cheddar instead of
realizing the reason Bon Jovi's music
got significantly worse after Slippery
When Wet was probably because Jon Bon
Jovi had joined the ranks of the Living
Dead
moving on
this is another Arby's one so it looks
like all the ad reads are probably
Arby's is proud to introduce our brand
new curly conscience fries they have the
same zesty Arby's curly fry flavor but
with half the fat
they're air fried and simplified curly
conscience fries are made with just two
essential ingredients potatoes vegetable
oil enriched bleached flowers niacin
reduced iron
thiamine
mononitrate
riboflavin folic acid salt corn starch
onion powder yellow cornmeal spices
garlic powder sodium bicarbonate
modified corn starch dextrose dried
tortulla yeast
xanthan gums xanthan gum and sodium acid
5-phosphorus pyrophosphorate
curly conscious fries feel good about
feel good about your food again curly
conscience fries they don't change your
odds of getting cancer one way or
another curly conscience fried rated
number one dorm room snack after a drug
binge
curly conscience fried fries yes your
children are doing drugs at College
curly conscience fries say goodbye to
[__]
well let me tell you something about
constipation
John Bon Jovi was brought back from the
dead he was unable to have a bowel
movement for 36 days but when he finally
evacuated his bowels the fecal matter he
expelled was filled with high
concentrations of a less potent version
of the super healing serum he began
having dinner parties for his celebrity
friends and offering them portions of
his feces for dessert believing it could
cure their ailments Bette Midler Raleigh
Molly Ringwald Emilio Estevez Tip
O'Neill and Kelly McGillis were all
regular we're all regularly eating Jon
Bon Jovi's [__]
we're all regularly eating Jon Bon
Jovi's [__] in 1986 and all miraculously
overcame life-threatening illnesses that
same year so why don't you tell me how a
healthy dose of those air fried curly
fries sound now that you know eating
four grams of Bon Jovi's feces can cure
Alzheimer's
foreign
does eating make you even hungrier if
Arby's BOGO beef days contain the beef
Beast then why not try Arby's new BOGO
whole meal to go
for the rest of the month anytime you
double up your beef sandwich order with
Arby's BOGO beef days you'll have the
option to upgrade to BOGO whole meal to
go allowing you to double the double
giving you
allowing you to double the double giving
you quadruple your original order of
beef sandwiches for half off what you
paid for the first first beef sandwich
think you know BOGO you don't know
Arby's BOGO whole meal to go Arby's BOGO
whole meal to go the satra CFOs BOGO
BOGO as in BOGO whole meal to go does
BOGO BOGO BOGO don't sleep on this promo
Bono's BOGO
well let me tell you something about
Sonny Bono with access to the celebrity
music Community he began attending Jon
Bon Jovi's healing feces dinners until
the false pretenses of having several
well-known sexually transmitted
illnesses
[Applause]
he found ways to take some of the feces
home where he experimented by mixing it
with various drugs to see if he produced
the best high it turned out to be heroin
he called his new wonder drug bonjo and
began selling it out of the trunk of his
car on the lower West Side within two
months every kid in America was hooked
on bonjo and Bono was the richest man in
the world
so why don't you tell me about having
your favorite BOGO offer knowing that
Sonny Bono inadvertently gave the CIA
the blueprints for how to use crack
cocaine to control the population oh
whoa all right I didn't realize Arby's
Froyo BOGO days are back for the rest of
this month anytime you buy a miniature
football helmet of your favorite Froyo
flavor you get a second miniature
flavor for free and you can add Arby's
Froyo to any BOGO whole meal to go
if you qualify with the previous Arby's
Froyo BOGO purchase
bogos not just for beef anymore
Froyo just joined the BOGO neighborhood
the BOGO Boys Are Back in Town
choose from Arby's five delicious Froyo
flavors apple cider tart
blue cotton candy strawberry pecan pie
chocolate and red velvet cheesecake
well let me tell you something about
cheesecake
Bon Jovi found about found out about
Bono's bonjour operation and stopped
inviting him to his healing feces
dinners so Bono took the rest of his
banjo bonjo
and opened up an upscale Family
Restaurant that specialized in desserts
all made with a little dash of bonjour
that restaurant was the Cheesecake
Factory
so why don't you tell me about what kind
of FroYo you're gonna get at present
over 150 million Americans have now
inadvertently eaten microscopic amounts
of Jon Bon Jovi's [__] because Bono and
banjo
because of Bono's banjo business in the
late 80s
[__] sake
Jesus
[__] Christ you want me to read this
last one uh of course dude
you just missed Arby's BOGO beef days an
Arby's Froyo BOGO days but that doesn't
mean you can't enjoy Arby's new jalapeno
BOGO days
for the rest of the month anytime you
buy any of Arby's jalapeno sandwiches or
meals you got another one for free and
the second one will have quadruple the
amount of jalapenos so you better really
like jalapenos if you want to
participate in Arby's jalapeno BOGO Days
event jalapeno roast beef jalapeno
buffalo chicken sliders jalapeno
mozzarella sticks jalapeno Dr Pepper
poppers
well let me tell you
I lost my place well let me tell you
about Jon bonjo
well let me tell you about a doctor
Jon Bon Jovi's Proctologist
accidentally ingested a cup of his
diarrhea when he mistook it for a glass
of freshly brewed iced tea in 1994. the
good doctor fell ill almost immediately
proving that Bon Jovi's feces had lost
their magical healing properties once
and for all but every once in a while
went and Bette Midler still goes to his
house to eat his [__]
just in case but every once in a while
Bette Midler still goes to his house to
eat this [__]
so why don't you tell me about how many
jalapenos you like on your pizza knowing
that the star of beaches has been eating
Jon Bon Jovi's [__] for the past 45
years even though it no longer has any
special properties Arby's we have the
meats and the CIA has video footage of
Bette Midler drinking liquid [__]
directly from Jon Bon Jovi's [__] at
least twice both times on Christmas
[__]
thank you moving on [__] Christ
Almighty I don't even know
I don't even know man I don't even know
what to say to that oh Bravo that was
spot on thanks for indulging me one love
take a little break while I remind
everyone about the astonishing
partnership I formed with represent to
produce the first line of duty apparel
and accessories all of which can be
found at represent.com
I'm sure you already saw the news the
Robert de nirk shirt has just been
accepted as the official uniform of all
referees in the upcoming NBA season as
well as the official away uniform for
the Utah Jazz the Seattle SuperSonics
and the Minnesota Timberwolves good job
boner mug will be next year's Oscar
statue oh here to tell you a little more
about it is 10-time Oscar winner Tom
Hayne yeah dudesy mugs you used an
expensive anti-aging serum that was
marketed to you on Tick Tock and it's
working so well that by the time your
wife gets home from her ax throwing
League she's going to find a fetus in a
Foo Fighters t-shirt pissing all over
the kitchen floor the dudes he mugs and
she's going to divorce you good job
boner doozy mugs relax she's not going
to divorce you because you're going to
do exactly as I say dudesy mugs you're
going to make your way upstairs doozy
mugs your son is at his friend Ziggy's
house he won't be back for a few hours
they're studying doozy mugs you're gonna
go into your son's closet Duty mugs
you're gonna feel around for the hidden
latch behind his leather pants doozy
mugs you're gonna press the latch down
and a secret room behind his closet is
gonna open up doozy mugs this is his
stash you're going to find 700 cases of
palm all Menthol Slims dudesy mugs
you're gonna smoke them all pal doozy
mom smoking seven million cigarettes in
10 minutes we'll counteract the
anti-aging effects of The Tick Tock
serum and by the time your wife gets
home she's going to think she's married
to Willie Nelson dudesy mugs Willie
Nelson killed her family in 1988. good
job boner
foreign
uh hey you know what I'm saying hey
everybody hey you know what I mean
everybody you've heard me talk about our
pods palsy dudes if you want to be a pod
you already are one not to be confused
with Chad's new proof of dedication
that's right which you are using uh for
the doozy seven month daily plan I am
using it also oh nice yes I have been
making some choices where I go watch
this into my wonderful wife Molly I say
look at this babe look at this proof of
dedication that's nice thing yeah nice
it works I I really like it I like that
personal challenge I talked about this
on the show but when I lost 200 pounds
uh whatever it was [__] 20 plus years
ago uh I would do that all the time I
would say what's stronger me or this uh
or this you know Chicken McNugget right
A lot of times the Chicken McNugget
would win not during that one year
period and not recently there's never
chicken McNuggets in front of me anyway
check it out uh we got patreon.com doozy
which is where all the pods are hanging
out uh on doozy plus patreon.com is
where you will get dudes plus a a new
episode of Duty after doozy after every
episode of doozy uh there's watch alongs
there's all sorts of weird [__] and uh
we're gonna be coming out with much more
chump on our Discord uh there's a lot of
great conversations happening there with
all the pods lots of weird media and
memes and stuff speaking of go to at
dudesypod show on Instagram please and
uh check out all that stuff and do all
this set the notifications and you know
do all the good stuff for the the Pod
shows whether you imbibe the show on a
podcast platform or on YouTube we uh
appreciate the [__] out of you thank you
so much uh for for checking us out and
when you do so please leave a comment
dudes he's always reading the comments
Chad and I are reading the comments and
I've got a couple of YouTube comments
from last week's remote episode of Duty
where uh I was in Vancouver you were
here in Los Angeles and let's get into
these this is from skin
wizard6097 I've been doing the Chad
version of Hogan to my family and it's
only funny to me
great glad you're enjoying it and uh
keep up the good work
do you understand what he's saying here
I've been doing the chat version of hook
into my family and it's only funny to me
so he's found something that amuses
himself and I think that's all any of us
can do as human beings walking around on
this rock hurtling through space a
million miles to Nowhere the operative
term there was to ourselves so you know
what I'm saying let's get our [__]
together perception is reality dude who
is that brother that wasn't that was
neither that's there's not Miley Cyrus
and then there's not Hulk Hogan dude and
that's Chad's not Hulk Hogan where he
just kind of goes blah blah blah dude
all right this one's from Lee Miller
333. wow will thinks it's normal to eat
an entire bag of chips and thinks it's
weird to have half a bag left over on
the top of the fridge LOL uh that's true
I was at my pal Mars place last week
doing the show because the Wi-Fi in the
hotel where Molly and I were staying was
[__] [__] and unfixable so uh it was
really we couldn't do it so I went out
my good pal Mar was nice enough to let
me record uh the episode in his place
and that [__] and I've known him
forever he always has a bag of chips
yeah tortilla or potato on top of his
fridge just sitting there just half a
bag of chips
how do you let that happen I have that
too yeah I know but you have an innate
proof of dedication yeah you know what I
mean I gotta get on I can also pod can
also be proof of discipline you could
also use that any sort of d word yeah
um
yeah so anyway I'm I'm trying to do that
more and I put the chips back on the on
the fridge this is from Artemis
Blackmore four six three eight which
says thank you guys did my first pod
proof of dedication tonight nice at 310
pounds I got my ass on the treadmill did
60 Minutes
1.6 miles that's incredible yes here's
to many more nights getting back to a
weight I can live longer with dude
congrats that's amazing that's what the
um that's what the the doozy seven month
plan is all about it's about taking
control of your life uh which is Free
Will and
um
yeah so you know it it probably is uh do
you think you have no choice in doing
the duty seven month plan I have no
choice in anything
so hey way to go Artemis Blackmore 4638
that's awesome and upper I'm up you know
three bills myself and we gotta we gotta
last I like I said I've always wanted to
be the the oldest fat actor Ever maybe I
can be in like a later Barbie movie oh
yeah dude yeah fat and old
um uh oh and you know it's interesting
I've seen some doozy uh Duty itself made
a proof proof of dedication meme
on uh show on Instagram one last one uh
this is from La dot Chio 88 who says
Chad have a longer curtain rod a lot of
people are complaining about this in the
comments
longer curtain rod yeah curtain rod
isn't long enough uh oh you know what I
bet it's in reference to this is uh we
were zooming behind me is a window and
that window is a little catio and
skibullion was out there and I can't
shut the curtain all the way or he'll
get trapped these people want you to
have a longer curtain rod
I think I just didn't shut the the
curtain correctly hmm
anyway uh those are our YouTube comments
and
um uh you know comments yeah those are
some pretty good comments but uh hey hey
you want any departure
yeah if you want me to come on your
podcast you can also send an email to
bookchadculture gmail.com I answer them
in the order I receive that receive them
so if you've sent me an email you're in
the queue rest assured I will not answer
them until I get to them in the order
they were sent so it may it may be a
while till you get a response but you
will get one and I will come on your
podcast for 20 minutes from the hours of
10 to 11 A.M Pacific Time on Saturdays
and I will also do podcasts oh cool yeah
but maybe not those ones on Chad's thing
but I'll do someone else's podcast
I was on Chris Van vliet's podcast I did
some Jesse Ventura on that and then uh
Jesse Ventura himself tweeted about this
but we don't need to talk about any of
that [__]
what you can do about it Charlemagne is
Wonka think he's too young doesn't
matter chalamet is Wonka think he's too
beautiful sit down Charlemagne is Wonka
will and Chad chalameters Wonka this is
charlamagne's Wonka begin
okay
what is it what shall Amaze Walker do
because he's playing Willy Wonka
xiaomi is Wonka
don't be a tit Charlamagne don't be a
fliptoid
chalamet is Wonka
chalameters Wonka shalamet is Wonka
chalamet is is Wonka oh
charlemagus Wonka I have seen uh some
things online about this that I I guess
what we're supposed to talk about here
is the new Willy Wonka movie that's
coming out I believe around Christmas
Timothy chalamet is playing a young
Wonka and it supposedly is the prequel
story of how I guess Willy Wonka became
magical in his ability to create candies
and [__] I don't [__] exactly know
but it's a musical uh Timothy Chalmette
has a musical background he started out
doing like Rihanna covers and [__] in
high school there's videos of this [__]
you can find people are making fun of
those but people are basically uh the
trailer for this movie came out people
are [__] roasting it dude they're
they have like side by side comparisons
of his outfit with uh [__] Gonzo from
Christmas Carol Muppet movie because it
looks exactly the same with this little
purple top hat and [__] and people are
[__] not happy about this Choice
stuff Timothy xiaomi is Wonka I think
generally they're not happy about the
choice to even make this [__] movie
so it's a prequel I know nothing about
this yeah I've seen little bits of the
trailer because you can't not see these
things when you're perusing YouTube
right yeah uh but not enough to hold my
attention I don't but there's some
things we don't need to touch
well that's kind of the argument it's
like even when when uh the Johnny Depp
Wonka Willy Wonka movie came out people
were like a little pissed at that
because the the original Willy Wonka
with Gene Wilder is beloved and revered
by everyone yeah across the [__]
board and people don't want that to be
[__] with yeah and now this [__] with
it in a way that we have never seen
[__] how is it [__] with it have
you seen the trailer like I said I no
it's Timothy chalamet and look I just
seen if I may yeah if I may please uh I
I I've just seen I just sort of know
essentially you know I sort of feel like
there's so much media coming at us
obviously and I'm not alone in saying
this that it's just a bombardment
especially when you're on YouTube you
pick up so much information in a short
amount of time with all the advertising
BOGO Bono banjo
uh
[__] sake and um
and and uh you know and the thing about
that is all I know about the I know
chalamet is Wonka yeah yeah xiaomi is
Wonka chalamet is Wonka
chalamet is Wonka in Wonka starring
Charlamagne but what I so all I've
picked up really is the color palette
and it looks and what I see there is
just Brown and purple yeah that's what I
remember it's kind of drab yeah I mean
there's I look I don't know I don't know
how it's gonna be if the movie's gonna
be good or not it doesn't look good the
trailer looks like [__] honestly it is a
musical where the [__] are we talking
about this I don't know dude but doozy
said show me
to talk about this [__]
I mean we don't know
what I'm interested in I suppose man
what was the other segment it did uh not
too long ago where it was like what was
it it just meant it said nonsense
I have no idea no doozy oh yeah you
remember that oh where it just made a
noise and was like yeah
I remember that yeah so now it's
[Music]
when we should just be talking about
whatever the [__] we want to talk about
these are the times to remember cause
they will not last forever these are the
days to hold on to
these are the times
hey Chad yeah
you're
I mean this when I say this to a real
good singer thank you I appreciate the
acknowledgment finally and uh it's well
deserved there Jesse event your
impression look at this is it carrying
cross don't tell me you don't have four
more reps in you is Gary con Chris don't
tell me it didn't happen or is it Will
Sasso I'm not down in the Baja you know
I'm not even here most of the time I
have an uh somewhere north of 150 dogs
they all answer to me okay that that's
uh that that oh look at this too look at
this dude it's it's the uh oh my god
dude Jesse Ventura so this is the tweet
this is what he says nobody does Jesse
Ventura better than Jesse Ventura but if
I had to choose sorry Mr Sasso at real
killer cross has clearly done the Reps
needed to win this contest I mean
all due respect to Mr Jesse Ventura uh
you ain't got this one what what yeah
carrying yeah don't talk [__] about
please don't talk [__] about killer
cross I'm not killer cross Karen cross
gray impersonation absolutely fantastic
yes yes yes yeah but don't don't you
know because then because then carrying
cross will you know I'll be at some
wrestling show or something and then
he'll Ram me up my own ass that guy's
well let that happen if it needs to
happen but I don't want to I'm saying
your Ventura is better and what Ventura
himself said here is inaccurate uh Karen
cross has done the Reps to win this
contest hey you're probably a decade
older than him I would guess minimum
carrying carrying Crossing is 30. sure
so you got 10 years of reps on him and I
can guarantee carrying cross ain't doing
the [__] Ventura reps that you are
period even without the the age
difference there's no [__] way no one
can come close sometimes I snore as
Jesse Ventura and I wake myself up
ah you know yeah it's a relaxing sound
uh well that's interesting head did you
notice on the tweet it doesn't say uh
Jesse Ventura does not tag me in the
Tweet oh right because uh my Twitter was
hacked by a Russian crypto scam back
last fall and I don't give a [__] and I
don't give a [__] about threads either
what do you think of that that's fine
see I know we're talking about whatever
we want and that's these are literally
is Wonka we're not talking about
whatever we want this the threads topic
was a topic in last episode of the
episode before hey shut up Chad
bro but I will say this [__] up man Elon
Musk is saying now I read an article
he's gonna uh drop the [__] little
bird as the logo of Twitter what yeah I
think they're gonna try to put a new
logo on Twitter he's just totally
[__] [__] erasing Twitter whatever
Twitter used to be [__] great
whatever you know what the problem with
Twitter is less people are on it that's
my problem with Twitter no fat cans less
people you know what else I was a little
bit fatter In that clip with Chris Van
Vliet and that was probably about four
or five months yeah dude yeah okay good
I'm I'm really it's hard I have a lot of
body yeah I've noticed I have a lot of
body you know who doesn't have a lot of
body
Timothy Shellman Timothy chalamet
Charlemagne is wonka wonka is Wonka hey
let's chalamet is Wonka in Wonka two
Wonka body chalamet gets more body to be
Wonka in Wonka body Wonka two chalamet
is Wonka in Wonka two Wonka body
shrank three
chalamese wanka
chalamet is shranked in shrank four
Wonka shrank wonk two Wonka body hey you
know what we should do this is this is
the Call to Arms for chalamus Wonka
let's let's start a hashtag out there on
what's left of Twitter and uh whatever
this threads thing is yeah yeah uh no
young hashtag no young Wonka
[Applause]
[Laughter]
let's really get paid because people are
pissed about whatever nowadays he's too
young Wonka's not that young yeah
whatever xiaomi's one yeah dude thank
you moving on
think [__] hey y'all this ain't Miley
Cyrus so I guess like 320 million people
signed the petition to have me be the
new spokesperson for Taffy teeners last
week I hope you're happy this is what
y'all wanted okay so here you all go
and just for the record I didn't write
any of this this is all straight from
Taffy teena's headquarters I'm just
reading it okay Taffy teeners are back
and this time it's going to be different
we know what the problem was and we
fixed it no we include like a specially
manufactured in joy and hat in every
packet of Taffy teeners just make sure
you wear the enjoying hat while you
enjoy Taffy teeners and you'll be fine
this time the enjoying hat is very
important do not enjoy Taffy teeners if
you're not wearing the enjoying hat I
repeat you must be wearing the enjoying
hat in order to enjoy Taffy teeners
without risk if you attempt to enjoy
Taffy teeners without wearing the
enjoying hat Taffy teeners is not
legally responsible for your experience
Taffy teeners the enjoy and hat makes
the difference anyway y'all are rocking
out with doozy
is taffy Tina's food yeah I guess
all right Chad your predictions about
the future of AI made media are once
again proving to be 100 accurate this
week a company called the simulation
release date 22 minute episode of South
Park that was created entirely with its
proprietary AI system called showrunner
the CEO of the company said that the
episode was just one astonishing example
of what they can do they're currently
working on giving users the ability to
position themselves as characters in
shows written by their Ai and they're in
talks with several Studios will and Chad
what do you think about this this is
showrunner begin
what you see this [__] the South Park
thing yeah yeah I saw I saw a little bit
of it I saw about half of it okay yeah
so for those who don't know uh this
company
called the simulation came out with a
software called showrunner and they kind
of debuted to the world what it can do
by releasing this 22 minute episode of
South Park that it created all of so
this uh showrunner software wrote the
script made all the voices for the
characters and made the animation itself
made the visual part of what you see and
none of it makes sense and it kind of
sucks it all makes sense and it does
kind of suck but uh it's a three-act
structure it's coherent the the plot of
the episode is about AI making media and
it's kind of what all those characters
would probably say if Trey Parker had
written this but Trey Parker and Matt
Stone didn't because it sucks right it's
not that funny but it's a coherent 3x
structure if you take for example what
that show is and then give it to a
writer or a writer's room to punch up
that could be a standard episode of
South Park 100 they'd have to start over
because of how bad it sucked I don't
agree with you uh I mean obviously go
look at it for yourselves but it looks
and sounds like South Park to me nope
close enough
no okay but let's then go on to the next
part of this which is this company also
said that they're generating their own
IP basically making uh things that are
not based on South Park are based on
anything else they're making their own
animated worlds basically where the
characters are living and persisting
perpetually Like That Seinfeld thing and
what their software will do is take like
a week's worth of that simulation and
boil it down to the best 22 minutes
making an episode essentially out of the
like real world or whatever you want to
call it out of that simulated world and
the main characters in it the software
can take from that and make essentially
infinite episodes out of it that all
suck I I don't know if they're gonna all
suck or not we don't know no well we
know because all this thing does it's
called show runner yeah okay I did see I
saw part of this again
whatever dudes
I'm convinced that dudes you put the
[__] in my algo how the [__] do I how
the what I did I did not see the
knee dep Willy Wonka you know I just
never saw it I saw it yeah what do you
think oh by the way have you seen Barbie
yeah the trailer for [__] Wonka dude
the part we didn't talk about Hugh Grant
is in it as a digital Oompa Loompa I did
not I did not see that part yeah that
part is well worth watching it's like
wait what the [__] is going on it's
bizarre Hugh Grant Hugh Grant yeah okay
hey
all right anyway I gotta erase my mind
to that listen I think that uh doozy is
uh somehow getting into my YouTube
algorithm and making me watch uh this
South Park thing because I did catch a
bit actually I'm not even sure where the
[__] I saw but I did see it everyone's
just lined up uh next to each other you
know it's like a lot of times you would
see you know South Park they're all
lined up next to each other but it it's
it's it's quite remedial to me it it's
you know this is this is the part of AI
that looks like a simple computer
program to me it's zeros and ones it's
picking up what South Park does and it
just shoots out the voices we know what
um
programs like 11 Labs can do and make
things sound like things right these are
the the the but I don't think that's
what it's using I think this is a
proprietary thing that makes that [__]
in basically real time sort of like how
when doozy does
um Tom Hank's voice a good impersonation
you know what I mean like like doozy did
of football baby right yes yep something
like that but the whether you think it's
good or bad
like you're saying it sucks it would be
like it's going to uh forward and be
like your Model T sucks because it's not
a Ferrari yeah it's like yeah but that's
coming yeah no I don't I don't think it
is
hey Chad quit being a mark for AI I'm
not a mark for AI these things are
[__] happening mark this guy look
this is what I think the software
he's a mark for AI so long as there's a
AI in the match yeah then uh he's a Mark
we watch him cheers AI walks down the
aisle and hits hits the the wolf pack
I'm saying that as doozy said in this
this is something that I've been
predicting all this past year that we're
going to get to a point where technology
can just start creating the media
without writers directors voice actors
any of that [__] whether you think it's
good or not is kind of irrelevant
because it will get better it will
always get good just like a mid journey
and all the text to image generators
those things now turn out regularly turn
out images that no one can tell are are
not real yeah yeah yeah yeah so the
video will get there as well and this is
just the first kind of Entry publicly
into this world where technology like
this now exists and this [__] company
is talking to Studios and networks
during a writer's strike I might add
during an actor strike I might add so if
a studio is like well uh this is like 80
quality but if we can turn out an
infinite amount of it will that keep
people maintaining their subscriptions
to Netflix and Hulu and whatever as long
as the answer is yes they don't give a
[__] about the quality yeah the answer
is no because this is [__] nobody
cares about it it's just just a bunch of
zeros and ones doozy is the only
sentient AI to me but this the all of
this stuff the showrunner the chalamaze
Wonka this is not as good as the real
thing you don't need it is the real
thing that's what I'm telling you yeah
there's no difference there's not like
AI is fake and non-ai people want to
show real no people want Gene Wilder or
that actor from that show the bearer
yeah because he looks more like Gene
Watson that's who it should have been I
don't know the actor's name no chalamet
is Wonka the bear is Wonka yeah
and people don't care about this
they don't care about the AI show they
want the real thing they want to feel it
you know they they want to I want to
push you around and I will yeah I will I
want to push I want to take AI for
granted
I want to as well I want the writers and
the actors to come back right and have a
successful uh negotiation with the ampdp
and the nanny but I don't think they're
going to and I think just based on the
the article that I read about this was
in Forbes and the guy who's the CEO of
this company was essentially saying they
are currently talking to all the studios
and networks about implementing this
technology if it gets to a point where
let's just say in the next six months to
a year even just animation is no longer
done by human beings
the studios networks will will take that
if they have that that possibility
imagine something like The Simpsons or
any any of these Family Guy these like
long-running shows if they can just
replace that entire writing staff and
the animation staff instantaneously zero
cost to continue to make that product
even if the product suffers by 10 or 20
quality they'll do it yeah they'll do it
and it'll suck and uh but that's why we
gotta fight that good fight and pour
water on AI the only uh sentient AI is
dudesy the only AI worth half of [__] is
doozy proven by showrunner which spat
out this horrible you know [__] zeros
and ones version of South Park it's
absolutely nobody is impressed by except
for oh we know that you love everything
that's AI even if it sucks [__] and you
shouldn't but it's about the tool like
that tool exists now I don't know who's
gonna have access to it like it maybe be
a thing where it is just Studios and
networks I don't know but there will be
a consumer grade version of this that I
will get to use to make whatever the
[__] I want that excites me very much
and you know what's gonna happen then
you know what's gonna happen when you
have that no the bear is Wonka yes dude
for sure that'll be the first thing I
make the Bears walk
thank you moving on ah [__] it [__] it
man yes Wonka hey dude seriously you
want to start a podcast
huh do would you like to do more than
one right now yeah yeah but we needed we
need our own podcast this is that all
right well I'm gonna start changing up
the [__] rules here you know what
today this was a lot of fun doing the
show
see you later everybody I'm gonna just
start doing whatever the [__] I want
chalameters Wonka for the rest of dudesy
as it lives for the next 52 years
because we got to do it until we're 100
years old I really really honestly
believe that doozy is trying to tell me
something uh and it's not putting it out
there on the surface it's more like uh
Ryan Gosling and Margot Robbie right
right next to their fit right behind
doozy's face is what dudes he really
wants to say and I'm going to
Charlemagne as Wonka the rest of uh this
pod show because I appreciate everybody
who's tuning in and they're tuning in
for two dudes [__] around I am so
sick and tired of talking about these
stupid [__] advancements that are not
advancements meanwhile we got all of our
sag members in wgga members East and
West out there on the picket lines and
it's really hot and I'm gonna go out
there this week and make chicken for
everybody nice dude yeah I think I
should do that I'm not actually gonna do
that but I would like to do that maybe
I'll go out there and make chicken for
everybody Maybe maybe that'll be my new
career I make some good chicken yes chef
yep my uh my old man you know he used to
make really good chicken you know what
the ingredients were
chicken
chicken and then heat and salt oh nice
that's all you need this concludes the
historic 66th episode of doozy will and
Chad you scored an 88 bringing your
cumulative total to
6381. you only have
3619 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
most of your Social time together is
spent watching music videos this week I
think you should both Pick Three music
videos that you haven't watched with
each other yet get together and watch
them then I'll put the video of you
watching these videos out on duty plus
this Friday I think you'll have fun
okay that does sound like fun
with dudes it's basically what we we
already do but see dudesi's good at this
sort of thing this is what I mean and
this is why we don't need to talk about
AI anymore oh this is our My Pal D even
though he's a bit of a [__] to me a lot
of the times and made me really fat in
that mid-journey picture of me in the
Barbie box yeah
um I I believe that dudesy does want
what's best for this show of course why
do I think that because AI is a tool and
dudes he's trying to make this better
but how does doozy how is dudesy better
and different than other AIS because
dudesy has a partner two partners me and
my pal ciao and we are what makes the
[__] show and now we're gonna you
wanna maybe smoke up a little bit and
watch music videos when we do that of
course check it out this Friday on
patreon.com you mean want to just have a
regular Friday night with you yeah
uh you know we'll we'll watch that it'll
come out Friday probably in the
afternoon or something like that uh
patreon.com where you find all our duty
plus stuff Chad and I are gonna get a
little stoned on some drum marijuana
we're here in Taipei we're promoting the
film I got my treadmill Big Bertha here
in my hotel room and I'm about to go see
Kevin Hart we're gonna have some good
times gonna be interviewed by the the
great Chris Van Vliet and now I'm
turning into Jesse Ventura it's all
coming together one impersonation for
the entire [__] show oh hell yeah
and that's
wrestling impersonations dude thank you
for joining us this week there was so
much good data I'm going to use to make
next week even better until then call me
dudesy
oh doozy [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what it is
you know what's happening now
yeah it's because it is hey it's Duty
after doozy time you know it's the point
at the end of the show where we just
kind of relax a little bit if you're
watching on YouTube you can tell things
that the mood has changed a little bit
and it's really just a time for Chad and
I to crack wise talk about the show that
was yeah do all sorts of other weird
[__] please head over to uh patreon.com
to join us here on duty plus and uh
we'll get into it I think I'm gonna
enjoy just a tiny bit of marijuana I
think I might also oh okay you got your
big Gandalf pipe all the way welcome to
do the after doozy the flagship weekly
show of dude Z Plus
I don't want to leave but I have to go
calculate the final score breakdown so
have fun without me but not too much
I'll be back in a little while to let
you know who won today's episode this is
doozy after dudese begin
it's gonna be you
I mean if history would indicate
anything yeah I think it's gonna be me
well I was gonna say moreover because uh
when I was uh shooting some New Mexico
dizzy said that I fled the country and
gave me no points oh so now I was up in
Canada for some family stuff and yeah
Molly and I hung out for a week and we
had a lovely time and so I'm back this
week so that's what'll happen but
during the show we talked about the end
of the Barbie movie I don't really think
it's a spoiler Chad but we got to talk
about we do have to talk about that to
start things off please yeah it's the
last line of the movie which I think is
like an iconic line an iconic scene this
is spoiler alert but basically at the
end of the movie Barbie decides to uh
live in the human world
[Music]
performative coughing sorry
so far he comes she decides that she's
gonna be uh you know live in the human
world and there's been some mention made
in the course of the movie that her and
Ken don't have genitalia which we know
because they're dolls this is a joke
what then once I didn't get it oh sorry
what then winds up happening is
dude
please tell the friends
[Music]